the future hall-of-fame kicker here on
the program how are you Adam
I'm doing very well what do you think of
when you hear that call from Gil Santos
all these years I still kind of get
goose bumps thinking about it freeze
right back to that moment I don't care
how many times or whatever the first
time you have an opportunity to win a
Super Bowl stays much forever that's for
sure
so walk me through those moments best
you can recall them Adam when you made
that job you know we weren't expected to
even be in the game it was a 21-point
underdog before we started coach
Belichick had a real good game plan that
we were going to we were going to try to
bug all their receivers on the line of
scrimmage just really attack him on the
line of scrimmage not let him release
well well seemed to work out well we've
got a couple turnovers and got off to a
nice lead they came back and tied it up
with about a minute and a half left and
I remember John mad saying my ally she's
probably just dealing going to overtime
and we decided to let Tom Brady and the
boys try their magic one more time and
March it down the field which which they
did and and you know very meticulously
that just 10 yards here 10 units they're
locked the ball and I got an opportunity
to run out there and try my luck on a 48
game winner 48 yard game winner in the
Super Bowl to put icing on the cake well
I say it's funny because if you think
about that at the kid and having the
opportunity to play in the Super Bowl
and to try to put your stamp on it at
the end but what's amazing it could have
been any any more surreal any more
perfect for a situation and the guys up
front
Ronnie fashion and Kent Walter my aunt
Safran older did a great job and when
the ball left my foot it felt good but I
had to had to look out make sure it's
going to the right spot and then it was
just celebration from there did somebody
say who do you remember if anybody said
anything to you before you went on the
field for that kick you know before
every game winner everybody kind of
treats you like you've got some
contagious disease they don't want to
talk to you they won't look at you they
won't touch it but a will is McKenna's
lawyer boy we're the only two guys in my
whole career that really much said
anything to me before for that
stuff and not and I think I think it was
lawyer standing there and as I trotted
out he it gave me a little spot on the
button said come on man let's get this
page you know that kind of thing so most
of the time they don't say much at all
but it's kind of weird you know you see
in the movies when when I when a big
play or something like that happens you
know they always portrayed in the movies
like slow-mo and everything gets quiet
and it really it really kind of feels
like that it really does you know I I
could I was aware of everything that was
going on around me you could hear the
John our team and their team talking
back and forth and then trying to say
stuff to me but it really slows
everything down and it just really focus
in on on your little world
I guess the crowd and the noise and all
that stuff all went away and I just
thought about you know the ball coming
to the older and meet you in my job so
it was it it it still is amazing thought
feeling when I when I think back to that
day and it's some of the other days it's
pretty well yeah it's not your only
game-winning kick in the Super Bowl the
NFL Network's first ever Super Bowl it
was the one and you ended against the
Carolina Panthers in Houston and then of
course that kick that we're talking
about doesn't happen if he didn't make
the one in the snow and the so-called
Tuck rule game Adams so I mean is is
that which is the biggest kick you think
you've made in your career I think I
think for sure the most difficult the
most pressure-packed would be the one in
that divisional playoff game and the in
the snow against the Oakland Raiders
they call it the snow ball or whatever I
think just sheer here difficult you know
I mean there's six inches of snow on the
ground where you know we're down by
three you know no time left on the clock
a yeah I don't think you could portray a
more crazy situation or more difficult
situation for you but you know
fortunately you know fortunately we went
out there and it's probably a pretty low
percentage kick you know everybody asked
me when it first happened and I you know
probably you know 5050 and then I look
back and think back at it and it's
probably a lot less than that but I made
the one that I needed to and it like you
said some of the other stuff maybe never
happens I know the first Super Bowl
doesn't ever even we
have an opportunity to play in that if
we don't win that game so I think that
one's probably the one that that I'm the
most proud of because it's probably the
most difficult kick I've ever had but
there's something like kicking a game
winner in a Super Bowl and being world
chants that never ever gets all that's
for sure I notice you just described
that game in three different ways except
calling it the Tuck roll game Adam
that's fast that was well done no it's a
it was an interesting situation I still
get people from from the Bay Area the
Oakland area that still gives me a tough
time over you know the rule was the rule
they changed it after the fact but the
way the rule stated it was the right
call and thank goodness for for us we
had another opportunity you know Adam
Vinatieri here in the Rich Eisen show I
don't know if you've not been following
the NBA Playoffs at all Adam the reason
why I bring it up is how drew bledsoe
got thrown in the middle of this Celtics
playoff run because Terry Rozier once
referred to the Milwaukee Bucks Eric
Bledsoe as Drew and then Bledsoe went
fired back at him and now Drew Bledsoe
has been thrown in the middle of this
thing rooting for a guy who's wearing
number 12 filling in for an injured
player wearing number 11 and has been so
open about it and seemingly so joyous
about it I'm wondering from your
perspective what it was like back then
with Bledsoe and Brady and seeing him
embraced as he is in Boston right now oh
yeah no I have paid a little bit of
attention obviously in Indiana I have to
I have to search around for Celtics
basketball and something like that but
not obviously not during the playoffs
it's easy to find it but but yeah you
know it it's kind of a cool situation on
what's going there and you know fans in
in in the Boston area are very very
fanatical they love their teams they're
very passionate about their sports and
they really rally behind guys and I tell
you what drew was with was a great
teammate you know he kind of helped
build that franchise to get us to that
point obviously played the Superbowl my
rookie year 96 and and kept the team you
know as the leader is the offensive
leader kept you know at a high standard
to play
standard but when he got injured and
Grady came in and kind of took over and
really became who Grady was I have a
huge respect for what true did he was
always supportive he was always there
help and he was I mean he stepped in in
the AFC Championship game through a
couple touchdowns that helped us win
that game and then turn around and and
graciously I don't know I mean I'm sure
was tough on him but he took the back
seat and the Super Bowl and and did
nothing but help the team win that game
and prepare that game and so he's a he's
a heck of a dude heck of a teammate and
I got all the respect in the world for
how he handled that situation because it
could have went a million different ways
and he was very professional about it I
think not only does his teammates the
former teammates like myself appreciate
what he brought to the table but I would
have to think that all the fans there in
the Boston area the New England area
still love him because so much for
everything that he did for the franchise
before he hit through the here and now
Adam Vinatieri I want to hit the Wayback
Machine in particular to the day you
were a rookie undrafted and you're
playing for Bill Parcells what in the
world was that like Adam that was an
interesting time for sure I know coach
Parcells was not real big on rookies and
particular rookie kickers and I think my
whole training camp he challenged me um
every way he could you know if it was if
it was something like a you know when I
was taking field goals he would
literally stand in my line to kick the
ball or he would cast shadows on top of
where were you know or if he he was
doing anything he could to kind of play
some mind games with me which you know I
don't know what everybody thinks about
that but I kind of liked that I've
always kind of enjoyed you know being
right in the middle of the action and
kind of feeling that I've never shied
away from trash-talking or being in the
middle of that kind of stuff so it was
an interesting time I think the most
pressure that he ever put on me was was
before our third preseason game he
prayed before our team meetings on the
on the Saturday night before the game he
he came up to to all of us specialist
standing around waiting for the team
beating
all right senator here's the deal I'm
gonna see if you got what it takes so if
you pack up your and get out of here he
said you've got all the field goals all
the extra points all the kickoff I'm
gonna see if you can handle it or if you
if you're backing up and going home and
pretty pretty straightforward challenge
I guess and as far as that concerned and
I had a great game you know that game in
particular and made all my kicks and and
then the release mat bar the next day
which was a shock to me because that was
his long high kicker and probably his
favorite all-time kicker and done so
much and helping him you know win Super
Bowls in the past that that for him to
actually give me the opportunity to try
to do this was was pretty impressive but
he was always a guy that was trying to
challenge not only me but all of his
team you know he wanted to make sure he
had guys that he could trust going into
battle and do it that they had what it
took is it true that you didn't really
make your bones with him until you made
a tackle on special teams of Herschel
Walker is that a true story well you
know I probably I think at some point I
know after after that game and being
able to run down her show and tackle him
he made a comment to me because you're
more than just a kicker to this team now
you're going to be looked differently by
your teammates and I wasn't sure that I
understood what that meant but after
that it did change and I think everybody
treated me a little bit different you
ran him down Adam Vinatieri you run you
run down Herschel Walker man look at you
we're watching it right now on the TV
feed a couple more minutes left without
a military Indianapolis Colts kicker
let's turn the page now and you're
entering your 13th season with the
culture just three more than you had
with New England how is Andrew Luck Adam
no come along yeah you see much much
better I easy big and strong he's doing
a bunch of stuff in the weight room and
running around his progression is is
increasing and I think everybody is very
very content and happy with with this
progression at this point having to I
haven't seen him running live reps with
the offense or anything yet but I don't
think that's very far away I can't you
know I can't speak as
I'm not a doctor I don't want to comment
on on that or even how far out he is but
he looks good he looks big and strong
and healthy he's got a great attitude
and everything it's kind of showing that
he should be back and ready to go and
how is the Frank Reich administration so
far I mean it's amazing right Adam I
mean what what what Frank was in the
league 23 years ago when you when you
join now here you are in your 23rd
season and it's Frank Wright getting his
first shot as a head coach
no he's a great man I love his passion
and you know he's very he's very
structured is a good way of saying that
I guess he's got a plan and we don't
deviate from a plan so it's easy for all
the guys to to rally behind him and
drink the kool-aid so to say because
we've made we've hidden we've made huge
adjustments and changes in attrition
around the building and our weight and
lifting programs to make sure that we we
can try to minimize injuries that
minimize I mean it's football we all we
all understand that there's going to be
injuries and stuff like that but we're
trying to do everything we can to get as
healthy and strong and and everything
that we can he's got a it's got a great
game plan that he's putting into work
and and all the new young coaches we've
got a listen we've got a young football
team we've got a young staff but the
amount of energy and excitement that's
in the building right now is is
unparalleled to anything I've seen in
the past it it's awesome everybody's
excited and fired up and and that keeps
everybody really really moving in the
right direction so you know I
young is good I think we would be by far
the youngest if I didn't skew those
numbers by being 45 years old we'd be by
far the youngest I'm sure but but I know
it is awesome I you know it's we're it's
a work in progress obviously but we're
making big big gains already and it's
it's only a couple more minutes left
with Adam Vinatieri here on the Rich
Eisen show so much being made that the
kickoff is going to be extinct it does
appear that the NFL's taken one last
swing at making some rule changes to
keep the kickoff as intact as it could
be as a part of the game what do you
think of the rule proposals that are
gonna be placed in front of ownership
next week Adam
well honestly I feel like any rule that
makes the game safer I like I'm for
obviously you know obviously we we try
to set a standard we know it's it's
tackle football there's big men running
around real fast and hitting real hard
but some of these new rule changes on
kickoff are trying to alleviate a big
impact plays you know the two-man wedges
that that guys are running down the
field full-speed these guys are running
the other way and it's just a the
biggest collision in football so they're
trying to alleviate some of that I'm
still a bit of a traditionalist I I hate
it when football starts to change and it
doesn't look like football anymore but I
think these changes are probably going
to be for the better it's it's really
going to be interesting on how special
teams coaches try to find a way to gain
an advantage and some of the things that
they're going to how they're going to
scheme and how they feel like that they
can you know are they gonna kick it
short and make teams return it are they
going to try to go ahead and kick it
deep and get a touch back and just you
know give up that extra five yards
versus you know trying to pin them down
farther so it'll be interesting you know
and whatever they do these kind of rule
changes it takes about a half a season
so you really see the the change and
that what everybody's planning on doing
but there's always going to be a couple
wrinkles and you can't get rid of
kickoffs 100% completely I don't think
you need the onside kick you need some
of that stuff at the end of the game but
anything that helps helps keep guys on
the field and helps alleviate major
injuries and major concussions and stuff
like that I it's got to be a positive
thing last one for you who retires first
you were Brady I'm gonna have to see how
many years he's got he keeps saying he's
got five to seven more years if he's got
seven more years I'm retiring first I'm
not gonna lie to you I don't have seven
left in me coming up a couple more for
sure how many well you know what I sit
here and I go like this hey at the end
of this year if I if I played well if I
feel well you know my body feels really
good right now I really can't complain
you know we've got a good program our
training staff and everything put
together a program where I can be be
very effective kickin and and still be
strong and maintaining it and it takes
more work I'm not going to lie to you
obviously the older you
yet the more nutrition plays a factor
and sleep and and all the little things
extra extra time soft tissue work and
all that stuff but if if I feel is good
after the season as I do right now I'll
keep going and then you know and we'll
see you know if it's if that's two years
at that three years time will tell
all right Chris Brockman put in the Rich
Eisen show Twitter account Adam
Vinatieri demands to have his own
trainer in the building please put that
in there take care of yourself okay I
appreciate it thanks guys you bet that's
Adam miniature the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience